number one you need to love yourself man
and you need to love your own dreams I
told Elena when we got together I said
look I'll do anything for you anything
literally anything except one thing I
will not give up my dreams okay if I am
demanded to water down my dreams give up
my dreams alter my dreams to be with you
I will not do it okay because I believe
that if I give up on my dreams which
most people do they'll give up on
everybody in their lives and that's the
way it is today it's my dreams first
Elena of our marriage and then the kids
setting that expectation in the
beginning yeah yeah being a strong
person says Hey I'm going for what I
want
and I think she really trusted that hey
this dude this guy's who he says he is
need motivation watch the top 10 with
believe Nation Hey Kevin Carmichael and
I make these videos because you are
probably the most ambitious person in
your circle but you know you're capable
of more and you get that Push by
surrounding yourself with the best so
today let's learn from one of the best
Grant Cardone and my take on his top 10
rules of success enjoy
rule number two hustle like you are
broke come in your room are broke right
now you're broke you're like just dead
broke like like if I went and banged on
your credit card it would scream and
call the police
no uh alert 9-1-1 call them out right
now this cannot be used again
that's fine dude that's fine you still
need to have your dreams
you need to start dreaming now how old
are you dude
22 years old you got any money at all
but he's got a little he's got a little
diamond in his ear right here he ain't
got any money but he's like look at this
[ __ ]
I'm signing I'm Shining
huh I'm excited to come here come here
man yeah come here man come here
I got a little cubic
come on up here man 22 years old man 22
years old you know what I was doing
every night 22 years old how what do you
weigh man how much you weigh oh you got
one in both ears look at this get a
close-up can you get a close-up look at
that man oh he's so cool he's so cool
look he looks good too man looks good
okay look how much money do you have to
your name
a thousand bucks
what
I feel like a million bucks though yeah
yeah
either way bro you broke
you agree with that oh you're broke you
guys need to admit it you need to own
you need to know when you're broke the
man's got a thousand dollars
right he goes to jail today
he's broke
so so like but but that does not that
does not mean you can't dream
so right now what he's gonna do is his
dreams are gonna be like okay man like I
just wanna I just want to get a a two
grand
or I just want to get some of these or I
want to get a watch
that's not the dream folks
you know when you were a kid when you
were a kid 12 years old what do you want
you want a car I can't wait till I get
in the car you don't think about it I'm
gonna own a car dealership
do you think I want a car you don't
think hey man I'm gonna make a new card
it flies
right see that's why he ended up with
these little cubics
because his dreams aren't big enough get
off the stage
okay but he's in the right place he's in
the right place everybody agree rule
number three aim for Financial Freedom
I'm making 2.4 million dollars
[Music]
if I could figure out how to raise the
rent 200 bucks
531 units
see that's why the number of units is so
important
531
106 thousand dollars
times what
is what one point
see that creates another one million two
hundred and seventy four thousand
dollars of income a year I'm already
making 2.4 million dollars a year
bam
that traffic jam
okay I got more cash flow
I just gotta I don't have to go work I
don't have to beat stuff up
I don't have to go Uber you guys are I'm
gonna go Uber to what would you go over
to
you end up with seven dollars
same energy folks same energy
spend the energy going someplace getting
a vehicle that can actually get you to
Freedom
I don't want money this money I've had
this money here the whole time okay it
ain't gonna do anything
how many you got money in the bank right
now
it's useless
money is useless until it is put to use
people earn money and then they spend it
and you're just doing this thing
comes in it goes down you have to have
multiple exits on the way out how do I
get out of this deal I know people that
have bought real estate that they're
liking cash flows but they're like I
cannot I can never get rid of this piece
of property it's always going to be a
problem for me hang me around my neck
but it pays me a little bit of money
okay now if it's only one unit if it's
only one unit folks and it makes you 500
a month it's still only 500 a month
everybody agree that's why you don't
want to go small you got to figure out
how to do it big if you do it big if you
do it right if you have the right right
location the barriers to entry if you
have the cash flow that you need if you
get good debt on it I promise you you
will not lose money in this space
Warren Buffett said don't lose money
number two what
number three
exactly so when when I read that I'm
like don't lose money don't lose money
don't lose money
what do I invest in
oh invest in something that doesn't lose
money don't speculate don't buy stocks
like I don't want to trade a piece of
paper for a piece of paper it's a piece
of paper when you go buy twenty dollars
worth of Google stock what do you get
you get a piece of paperback
it's all made up
kids steal it anyway
okay I want something I can see would
you agree
okay I would rather have that that money
I'd rather take this money and say okay
here's a hundred dollars here's a
hundred dollars I'm gonna take the
hundred dollars and I'm gonna buy a flip
chart
this flip chart is more valuable
than that hundred dollars
if I use it
everybody agree okay so I want you to
write this down quit saving money
[Music]
the banks have brainwashed you
save your money save your money save
your money save your money the the Wall
Street also did this stay liquid stay
liquid stay liquid you want liquidity no
you do not want liquidity you want to be
illiquid and you do not want to save
money rule number four visualize your
dream my wealth ultimately it's not the
money I have it's the knowledge I have
and the belief I have in myself the same
thing for you
but I want to take you on this trip
because look number one you got to
visualize it you got to be able to see
it in your mind like possibility second
thing is you got to see it you know in
the physical Universe you can explain to
me what a Bougainville is you can
explain to me what a beach is you can
explain to me what uh the gym looks like
on the second floor in Cabo San Lucas at
this beautiful hotel we're at but
until I visually visually physically put
an image to the ocean to the whales to
the sunshine to the mountains until I
visually see it it doesn't become real
third thing you want to do number one
see it in your mind
I was I was doing a call today with
Percy Miller uh Master P and he's like
first thing you got to do is see it in
your mind he grew up in extreme poverty
in the projects and he says Grant first
thing I had to do is I had to see it in
my mind that I could get out second
thing I had to do was see a picture of
it in the physical Universe
uh that's how valuable the internet is
today is that you get to see things that
maybe are way outside your price range
you can see the lambo the rolls the big
house the trip you can see the
possibility of Elon going to Mars you
know and and all of a sudden all those
things expand possibilities so number
one you got to see it in mind too you
got to see it in the physical universe
and this also includes other people
examples of other people that are doing
great things I'm not just talking about
physical manifestation I'm not talking
about stuff I'm not talking about
watches and bracelets and rings and
houses and cars I'm talking about how
can you actually manifest something in
the real world that you have in your
mind how do you turn an idea
into reality
and these things that I'm sharing with
you'll make it a possibility uh when you
dig deep on them though it's like okay
well how do I get closer to people that
are doing those things because the third
thing is you got to get closer to the
thing you want if you want a gulf stream
or if you want to solve the water
problem of planet Earth you're going to
have to get closer physically closer
step on not just see with your eyes in a
magazine or on the Internet you need to
put your feet in the sand put your feet
on the jet
now that might mean that you got to go
fuel jets for a while you got to go work
at an aviation company an airport and
actually fuel them clean them wash them
maybe you got to be a flight attendant
on them put your feet next to them maybe
you have to become a pilot you're going
to have to pay the price though there's
no free lunch here for anybody including
my children there's no free lunch
there's no way to know what this room
feels like the expansiveness of this
room by looking at on the internet the
moment you can get in it it'll be become
even more real to you the fourth thing
is you got to put your feet in this deal
you got to put your feet in this deal
there's a there's a horse down there I
can you can visualize a horse you can
see the horse you you gotta touch the
horse in the fourth thing I'm sorry you
got to touch the hearts and the fourth
thing is you guys got to collaborate
with other people man you got to get in
the room with other people whether
you're serving water
if they don't invite you to sit down
then offer them money to sit down with
them if that doesn't work
um offer to serve them to sit down okay
this is a story of my life could be
wrapped up in these four things right
here number one see it in my mind number
two see it in the physical Universe like
see it in in some not physical but in
metaverse on the internet in a magazine
a picture of it third get closer to it
put your feet on it on the plane on the
horse on the beach in the hotel if I got
to go work there to do it and the fourth
thing is you got to network with people
that have stuff okay again uh I spent
some time this week with uh Dame Dash
she's like look you got to get close to
the action you got to get with the
people that are making the moves you
cannot make the moves from your own
neighborhood uh Percy Miller tell me you
cannot make the moves from the projects
you got to move from the projects and I
make the moves in the project quit
working street corners quit selling just
a product and start hanging out with
people that have scaled their their
think their ideas into a reality also to
make sure you're actually taking action
after watching this video I've designed
a special free worksheet just for this
video the worksheet will highlight all
the Lessons Learned in this video as
well as pull out our three favorite
learnings and quotes that will inspire
you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet design specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business I'll see you
there rule number five stay curious I'm
63 years old you know I'll be 64 in
March and you know I feel like I'm like
14 years old man I'm like let's roll
like let's let's go I'm ready to run
through walls and you know flying learn
new stuff I'm studying uh cryptos right
now in the metaverse and like what
happens and when do I make a play and do
I make a play and what is all this so
you one number one you have to stay
curious
[Music]
number one curious you have to be
curious when Clubhouse came around
Clubhouse is an audio app if you don't
know what that is
a couple years ago most of people in my
office including Jared was like man
ain't nothing there's nothing there
you know I'm like oh there's people
there though
there's people there and what I
discovered because I was curious about
Clubhouse is not because I was curious
about social media I was curious about
people
to me I get energy from people
and so
um I've been in rooms where uh Alan have
y'all met Alan yet
so Alan Alan saw me go in a room one
night and he texted me he's like what
the hell you doing in this room man and
I said what's up he's like get out of
this room
and I said what you worried about he's
like you're the only white person in the
room and the title is white entitlement
[Music]
and he sends me a little sweaty emoji
I said bro where how am I going to learn
about white entitlement with white
people
like you got to be curious folks just
because it has nothing to do with you
doesn't mean your Market's not there and
for me to be able to Market to a market
means I need to understand how that
market thinks
so one of the great benefits of me being
curious particularly about two-way
communication on on social media the
feedback
I'm not looking for likes and comments
I'm looking for something some
electricity in the moment what you're
talking about the drive potential
potential and idea like all my ideas
come from I don't fabricate ideas
everything you see me do happened it was
happening already in the universe
I don't I don't create anything I just
grab something that's already there
and I grab it out of something I hear
so the Supreme Court today announced
they kicked out the Mandate uh for the
vaccine I'm like hey man
okay good you like it or don't like it
you all need to get on one side of that
story and start talking to people about
it so you gain that audience
you need to you need oh I don't want to
be political
say that's stupid man
you know there's nothing that raises
more money than politics
nothing there's nothing
and most of it's just a scam and
everybody knows that they're like I'm
throwing in they ain't throwing in for
their side they're throwing in to keep
the other side that they're worried
about
the point of the story is there's energy
there there's tremendous amounts of
energy that you wanna you wanna tap into
if you could walk the line and play both
of them that'd be super cool
very difficult to do that though
so when that came out today I'm like
good job man like I got to take a stand
on that now will I lose some people 100
percent
I don't care who I loses 8 billion
people on this planet I'm worried about
who doesn't know me
so the way to protect your brand
the way to protect your brand is to
expand it that's the only way to protect
your brand rule number six be the first
man did you hear that the that the
person that won the lottery I got two
points to make here the person that won
the lottery is 84 years old her name is
Gloria
McKenzie here in Florida she'll pay no
state taxes on that winning I keep
telling you guys move to a tax-free
state so that your income's not taxed
and hey if you win the freaking Lottery
380 million freaking dollars you
wouldn't be taxed at 10 or 13 percent
what are you thinking man the second
Point here is this this woman would not
have won this lottery ticket had it not
been for the guy in front of her being
so gracious to look at 84 and say hey
lady you want to go in front of me I
guess he was worried that she died
before she could buy the ticket okay
folks in my book called if you're not
first your last I basically explain look
man if you're first in line you don't
give it up to an 84 year old I know that
might sound you know without compassion
and and uncaring and not sensitive hey
when you're buying a lottery ticket get
in get out as quick as possible if
you're not first your last in this case
I hope 84 gives this guy a little
squeeze of the cheese please
let's find out how gracious 84 is with
her 380 to the guy that got out of line
to get her in the line to buy the ticket
that won the money well she don't pay
any state taxes in Florida rule number
seven learn how to sell this isn't a
magic act these are basic skills
and basic skills are duplicatable and
the reason most salespeople have such
trouble is because for years we have
been trying sales professionals and the
gurus have been teaching uh manipulation
tactics
Dodge the question
don't answer control the customer uh the
the whole neuro Linguistics book
these are gimmicks we have never hired
one person that had a neuro-linguistics
background that worked for us
successfully
so you guys are in the NLP stuff I'm
just telling you we've hired hundreds
and hundreds of sales people I've been
with tens of thousands of sales people I
have never seen one
person that got into this neuro bull
that was a successful salesperson over
long periods of time and did not bring
drama to our organization
I don't want drama dude I want
production
so so when when he sits a certain way I
don't start thinking about man
um imagine being in a sales sales
presentation I'm like I got to be like
him and then now I got to be like her
and now I got to be like him guess who
you can't be when you're doing that you
you man what a diss
I want to be me the power resonates for
me My Truth my authenticity and my
transparency
Okay so
if you can't do that you can't build you
can't build a business and you certainly
can't duplicate it I never ask him to be
me I'm like hey bro when somebody says
the payments are too high what do you do
what do you say well I'm with you
everybody try that
no no I just say it like that I said I'm
with you see and I'm with you
hey man hey the price is too high I knew
that before you did
everybody try that
okay CeCe he gets to be him but the
words will work because all I'm doing is
basically agreeing with the customer
this isn't a trick here okay uh this
course is uh I'm doing a dinner tonight
for 25 000 at my house okay I think we
got two slots left
the entire 25 000 goes to the Grant
Cardone Foundation any of you want to
put 25 Grand in please see one of my
people come have dinner at my house
we'll spend a couple hours over there
the money's going to go to help kids
some of you in the room immediately say
oh my God 25 Grand that's a lot of money
man I know that
you don't think I know 25 000 is a lot
of money I'm the one that decided what
the freaking entry would be
I said what would be too much 25 Grand
25 Grand would be a lot of damn money
somebody gonna be like that damn that's
a lot of money okay and the people that
it's a lot of money that think small
that go small and don't want to help
won't come to my house and have dinner
and the people they're like dude I'd go
spend two hours with that cat man for 25
Grand to get pictures with him at his
new home with his family
with with eight or ten other people and
the money's going to charity and I get
to write it off I get to bang the IRS
who hates the IRS
well this is this is the chance to give
them a good friend
[Music]
okay so you see what I'm doing I'm
handling all the objections right now I
understand 25 Grand is a lot of money
man I know what you got to do to earn 25
Grand you got to do crazy stuff to earn
25 Grand and if you keep thinking that
earning 25 Grand is always going to be a
problem for you hopefully for everybody
in the room one day you're going to be
able to earn 25 000 every hour rule
number eight invest time and money all
commitments require investments in time
and money all commitments you cannot
make a commitment without time and money
being invested time and money has to be
invested you have to invest time and
money if it's not on your schedule
you're not committed if you don't have
money back by that time on your calendar
if it's not costing you money or you
don't have money deposited right there
you are not committed where you have
your money is where your personal
spiritual emotional physical commitments
go whatever your money is is who you are
most committed to
Wells Fargo Bank of America Citibank
you guys many of you got more money at
Wells Fargo than you have invested in
your own advertising the market
because you guys are committed to the
live
the Big Marketing scam of the universe
save your money
save your money
what you should do is you should get a
good job first of all you should
avoid borrowing money
unless it's for something that we think
is good for you
right
so first of all you should not borrow
money unless
it's one of our credit cards
where we give you points
one day
able to stay at a Holiday Inn for free
where by the way the buffets at the
kitchen are free you can eat all you
want not to mention that you're already
overweight but you could go there and
eat all you want for as long as you want
butter
if you just borrow enough money on this
card
to buy enough stuff you don't need
to pay us back one day if you can
right and then during the week when
you're not borrowing money from us what
you should do is spend your time getting
money to pay for the grant belt that you
bought and put on your credit card
but you can't write off about it so this
is what Americans are doing people all
around the world spend 40 hours a week
running around hustling
yeah they get a hundred dollars what do
they do now they run over here to the
bank drop off the 100 bucks then they
run back out do another 40 weeks pick up
a thousand dollars man had a great week
didn't I bang and then they run over
here and drop it off at the bank these
are the good Americans
the bad Americans go pick up a thousand
bucks go to the club and blow it
the good Americans run run around
collecting a thousand dollars five
thousand dollars ten thousand dollars
Hustlers Hustlers man hard workers they
they get sophisticated ugh I'm gonna put
a little money in the bank over here
over here at Wells Fargo I'm gonna have
a little over here at Citibank I'ma
spread this around
I want to be a slave committee not a
slave to a few
I'm going to give a little to Bank of
America I'm gonna give a little bit to
Citibank I'm gonna give a little bit to
the Wells Fargo I'm gonna give a little
bit to Fidelity and Merrill Lynch I'm
going to give a little bit to my IRA and
my 401k I'm gonna bust my ass I'm gonna
spend 40 years killing myself to make
sure all these institutions
have my money
where they pay me nothing
for the sake of security
right and then you guys look up one day
you're like where's my money at it's in
all these accounts by the way what do
those people do with your money when
they get it
they call me up
hey Mr Cardone
we got another dummy
guy spent goddamn he must have spent 160
hours put together a little Bank
extremely disciplined dumbass
and and he saved hundred thousand
dollars with us and we'd like to know Mr
Cardone if you would like to borrow that
money
his money
yeah I sure would because we know Mr
Cardone that you'll put that money to
work
okay this guy that gave it to us all he
wants to do is work
I'm like yeah send me that money bruh
send me that money okay and they by the
way they're not done calling me they're
going to call nine other people
they're going to take his 100 Grand and
they're going to say they're gonna
they're gonna lend it out nine hundred
thousand dollars of it and this is the
banking system
and that is debt by the way
that U.S dollar
okay they're basically multiplying money
if the bank doesn't keep it why do you
spend all your time giving it to them to
keep for you rule number nine always be
prepared you have to prepare for
inflation hitting you
and look I just want to give you a heads
up on this thing it's happening right
now I believe we're already in a
recession not to be a doomsday guy
because I think that there's ways for
you to take advantage of this but I just
passed one two three four five six shops
and nobody's in them
so the American Consumer has like 18
trillion dollars between cash accounts
and money markets you can't get Negative
right now when you see the bad news this
is an opportunity for you and your
family to actually expand not contract
so you're going to see bad news in the
headlines everywhere once the the
politicians start allowing uh the mass
media to actually distribute the bad
news and we're not talking about you
Crane and covid we're not talking about
abortion uh uh rulings because all that
is just distraction for the bigger
problem which is the economy
the economy is problematic okay you got
the FED pushing interest rates
a half a point yesterday
there was a rebound in the stock market
this morning I wake up the stock market
rolls over by a thousand points okay
there's going to be blood in the market
so I'm going to do a training on this
I'm going to give you a few tips right
now but I'm going to click I'm going to
give you a link to a training for those
of you who actually want to do something
about this and not just hear the bad
news and be woken up the first thing is
you got to wake up you got to wake up to
what's happening you got to know that
hey
what do I do now what do I do if this
happens one do not buy into the bad news
okay two you gotta expand into the
opportunity and it's very very difficult
to do uh you've heard of wealthy people
doing this before how they take
advantage of situations okay I'm gonna
show you how to do that whether you have
cash or no you don't have cash whether
you have credit or don't have credit
because during times of contraction what
happens is
for instance there's 32 million small
businesses in America many of you are
going out trying to start a new business
where what you ought to do is just kind
of slide sideways and go buy one The
Neighbor Next Door to you I mean from
laundromats to Plumbers to internet
businesses to coaching businesses you
name it chiropractors dentists like in
every sector that you're involved in
right now in your business or your
interest or your passion I'll promise
you
there are thousands thousands not one or
two but thousands of small businesses
like yours that are similar to your
passion that would feed your passion
that already have branding already have
marketing built in already have a name
already have a location already have
Revenue already have credit lines that
you can literally just slide into okay
but you're not going to do that you're
not going to do that if all you're doing
is buying into bad news so number one
you can't buy into the bad news because
remember all bad news sooner or later
beat out by the need to survive in the
economy to go on the economy will always
go on okay not just here in America but
around the world always always always we
always get on the other side of bad news
so the first thing you do is you got to
keep your head out of the garbage dump
you got to stay positive and trust me
when it goes negative
it is not easy to stay positive people
always like oh yeah I can stay positive
on my own probably not because you're
not going to be on your own you're going
to be surrounded by bad news everywhere
so number two you got to think about how
do you expand despite the fact that you
don't have money and you don't have
credit or you do have money and you do
have credit but you don't want to use
either one because you're terrified and
you will be
the third thing you have to figure out
to do okay is exactly what sectors will
survive long term
what sectors are going to win through
contractions because what happens in a
contraction what happens is weak
businesses get squeezed out weak names
get squeezed out okay a weak operators
get squeezed out and the strong come in
and take over that either the technology
takes over and disrupts the space or a
person typically a person or an operator
comes in and then scales that business
now what I'm going to look to do here in
the next couple years is actually
accelerate my expansion
accelerate my expansion because I know
how to operate I know the four things
you have to do in a business to make a
business successful there's only four
things you must do to keep a business
one profitable two expanding and three
flourishing the SE four things and only
four things okay I don't have time right
now because I'm with my family but but
when you click the link below what I'll
do is I'll give you a free training on
those four things that you have to do
look you'll get through this I promise
you you're going to get through this the
question is you're going to get through
it and you're going to do great you're
going to flourish and prosper you're
going to be like these businesses
waiting waiting
for traffic on rule number 10 the last
one before some very special bonus Clips
is never give up on your targets how do
you get through stuff you got to have
targets the thing that probably gets me
through everything is this where am I
going
you know what is the target
I can do anything for a short period of
time if it gets me to a Target
significant enough to change and improve
the quality of my life
I can do almost anything as long as the
target's big enough and changes my life
and the lives of other people if you
asked me to uh change a flat I'm like
bro I ain't changing a flat I don't know
how to change the flat I'll tear the car
apart just finding the little thing in
the back so I tried the last time I
worked on a car I was 16 years old I
tried to change a starter in a 1970 Ford
Maverick took me four days
and it should take like 12 minutes
uh because I don't know what I'm doing
so you know you need a Target that is
you know big enough
to change to change the quality of your
life
I need to Target big enough
to change the quality of my life
otherwise everything that pops up in my
life will become a distraction to my
life
so covid hit
bang man I just got more excited
I'm like okay nobody's stopping me from
this target
when the government tells me I have to
force a vaccine on the people that work
for me I get more resilient on my
position and that's got nothing to do
with the vaccine it's got something to
do with people forcing me like you you
cannot suppression never works folks
for people that are alive and committed
to a Target suppression is fuel
the attempt to suppress or stop
creates the greatness of Who You Are
Diamonds Are Made Under Pressure so
these moments that are tough like is it
really a big event is it one and a half
years of your kid's life where's the
Target because you're looking in the
past right now if I'm on the pass it's
because I lost my target
one of the things that
to me is the most difficult thing in my
entire career is becoming a top producer
because the moment you become a top
producer you become susceptible
and thinking you have the life
I grew up in a little town in Louisiana
a little small town about 60 000 people
you probably hear the accent
and uh I grew up in a middle class a
middle class family my my dad died when
I was 10 years old my mother raised us
and my mother constantly told me how
proud I should be of myself
how many of you got a mother like that
you should be so proud of yourself okay
every time my mom was my best friend and
every time I would have a success it
didn't matter whether I was 18 years old
or 48 years old anytime I had a success
she was the first person I called I
wouldn't call my girlfriend wouldn't
call my wife wouldn't call any of the
people that were closest to me I'd call
my mom and say mom you never believe I
just bought a real estate deal I started
this company I bought my first real
estate deal it's 38 units it's four
million dollars and she'd be like that's
awesome I love you Just the Way You Are
and I'm like okay okay thanks she told
me that a thousand times how many had a
parent tell you I love you that's great
that's great you made 160 Grand last
year
but I love you just the way you are let
me hear that okay that's right out of
the 10x rule I don't know if you know
that that's right out of the four
actions
anybody know what action it is
average average I'm doing well okay
there's four levels of action number one
is I do nothing
if I rewrote this book I would take that
out that's actually impossible to do
nothing at all is impossible try doing
it right now
to do nothing means you had to make a
decision to do something and not do it
this is actually not true I wouldn't put
it in the book If I rewrote it the
second level of action is
um to retreat this is what most people
do by the way
how many had a commitment to work out
today
and didn't
okay okay I was up late whatever you
came up with whatever reason I'm gonna
make the call by the way any retreat in
life any single Retreat is a discipline
and a commitment
to retreat when it matters
so so every time you make a decision you
just need to be aware that what are you
doing here okay there's only four things
you can do in any given day right you
could do nothing you could Retreat or
you could do this average
now I know you guys are being told that
you're the top
you're the top you're the best you made
it to Miami but I'm just going to tell
you right now ain't not a person in this
room is above number three
um
no I'm not there
okay and I know how much I'm grinding
every day how much I'm pushing every day
how how many how many hours I put in
today what's the maximum number of hours
you can do in a day
not if you add people
if you added people you got to think
beyond the 24th Thing Once you guys get
committed once you get committed then
you will come up with Solutions outside
the physical universe
okay you're already doing that your
space is your space is bizarre okay here
there's a bunch of people in the room
that
that like I don't know anything about
technology
I'm 61 years old I was born in 1958. I
am supposed to be outside of that moment
of Technology yet I'm probably one of
the top five social media people in the
world today
banging on Instagram and Snapchat and
Linkedin and Google Plus that'll go away
using all these mechanisms to try to get
attention so that I can operate
at this level 10x thing this massive
level that is always changing by the way
you can't 10x something people are like
man I'd write the book If I wrote the
book I'd write it 11x
I'm like that's because you don't
understand 10x dude 10x is a multiplier
it's 10x which is a hundred
okay so what what I do what I did in it
when Lehman collapsed I wrote the 10x
Rule and I wrote the book because I
realized I had done something wrong that
book was written for me
and the reason when I closed the book
The reason I was like ah whatever I had
figured out what I had done wrong okay I
had to embrace the the the idea that
three or four million dollars in a bank
and a house paid for and two cars and a
marriage and I got it better than
everybody else and my mama loves me just
the way I am was all this this middle
class
this American particularly here in
America how many of you live in America
okay in America the middle class it is
the sleeping chamber
on planet Earth
okay people come here people come here
they come from India and China come to
here to get a middle class dude I don't
want anything to do with this
okay your middle class you will not
change the world
you might change your house you might
change the education your little kids
get okay they get to go to Texas A M big
deal right he told me that he went to
Texas I said oh that had to screw you up
bad just going to college
well because what do they manufacture at
college
they manufacture average people at
college
so so I want to challenge you today okay
I want to challenge you today I want to
challenge you today to start thinking
hey wait a minute am I even a top
producer it's not about getting the
right answer it's about being able to
use the information in the right
situation
and so you have to go into a situation
knowing something's going to be stable
particularly in an environment where
there's a lot of variables and we live
in an environment right now with a lot
of variables with covid the mass the
election coming who knows there's a
million different things going on out
there you cannot you cannot add
another variable to that many variables
so the thing that you need to do is you
have to be the stable
person in an environment where there's a
lot of craziness going on I had so many
people tell me well it depends it
depends on the situation no dude you you
need to be the same person every time
regardless of the situation
because if you try to change to every if
you try that's the problem with this
whole adapting thing
if you're going to adapt to every
situation that happens in life you'll
never become anything
because you'll just be a chameleon one
second then a tiger the next Second and
then a kitty cat the next Second and
then he roadkill the next
[Music]
remember it's going on in the
environment and you'll never become
strong the strong you you should be and
and that this disparity in America
particularly in America and around the
world the disparity between the the
people that have something and everybody
else is getting bigger and bigger if you
don't like the way that is
if you don't like the way that game's
working out you need to improve your
skill set so that you can go get yours
for you and your family because it's out
there I'm just telling you the the
opportunities out there is whether you
want to open your eyes be conscious the
whole time go look at it and figure out
how do you get your share of the of the
American dream you guys are just getting
started you're not going to start right
here
you're going to start down there okay
probably in another city another town I
grew up in Lake Charles Louisiana no
money raised by a single mother I was in
debt at 25 years old the first thing
that I had to do in my life was not
learn a new skill
first thing I had to do to get my life
moving in the right direction was
self-development
it is vital it was vital for me that I
improved myself and I could start
depending upon me I had to show up every
day with some rituals some disciplines
and start getting myself to trust me not
trust others but trust myself to do the
right thing every day one of the things
that I started doing was beating the Sun
up every morning
I'm gonna beat that son up every morning
so that I have the discipline and the
control of over my life
so I knew hey before that thing pops I'm
gonna pop I'm gonna get out of bed
depend on myself get up at the same time
every day and for me that time
regardless of where I was was beat that
son up no matter where I am I'm gonna
beat that thing up so it gives me a
sense of control over my own life second
thing I had to start cleaning up my life
and my friends and my environment when I
was younger between 15 and 25 I was
doing crazy stuff in my life
wasting my weekends I have the same
weekends or for the week
I was drinking
fooling around with a bunch of bad
things bad people making poor choices
at 25 years old I cleaned it all up quit
going to those places quit using those
things quit hanging out with people that
did not have ethics and discipline in
their life that weren't committed to the
same things that I was
I wanted to build something in my life I
wanted to become someone and to do that
to become someone in the eyes of the
world the first thing I had to do was
become someone I could depend on so put
some things together three or four
things you can do every day to start the
day kick start your day get going in
your day to give you a sense of respect
for yourself accomplishment for yourself
look just beating that scent up every
morning gives me the sense of
accomplishment that I did what I said
said I was going to do that I woke up
when I said I would wake up and I start
building respect for myself start
believing in myself so that I can go out
into the world and maybe maybe maybe
today maybe today when I go into this
meeting that I'm dressed for maybe
they'll believe in me as much as I
believe in me and that'll show up in a
contract a deal maybe even some money
just because you're great doesn't mean
you don't want money in fact the greater
you are the more money you're going to
want so if you want great people
I I hear companies always talk about I
can't find great people because you
don't pay them anything man right so
like if I if I give you file for you 700
Grand right now can you swim
yeah you any good I'm okay yeah so if I
offer you 700 Grand right now say hey
dude you got to go swim after that boat
you got to catch it look you're not
going to worry about how cold the water
is the water's probably freezing ass
cold right you're gonna you're gonna if
you're Money Motivated
okay you're gonna fly in there but but
let's say I put 700 grand out there and
say whoever gets to the boat first
exactly well what Trace exactly what
would you do it would you do it probably
I think anyone in the anyone in the
world would do it I don't know unless
you're a billionaire and you're like
yeah then 700 you're not motivated by
seven exactly right you'd want more than
700 yeah you'd be like yeah I'll do it
but you know what I know billionaires
would actually be the first people to
hit the water exactly because they
understand money they understand man
it's worth me paying that price to get
the 700 because they know what to do
with 700 a lot of people are not Money
Motivated because they simply don't know
what to do with money every time they
get it they actually lose it there is
value in having a a a partner in your
relationships that is not stuck in
mechanics because the mechanics stop
people from the dream yeah
you know the new year you know I want to
do this I want to do that the resolution
stuff the big mistake that I make in my
goal setting is the moment I set a goal
I want to move to how to do it and when
I do that when I move to how to
it stops me really yeah immediately
because I don't have the money to do it
I don't have the time to do it
uh I don't live there I'm too old I'm
too young
I don't have the connections
uh I don't know how to write a movie
make a movie get a TV whatever right I
want a Netflix deal okay I don't know
anybody at Netflix so you move into the
mechanics and the moment you move into
the mechanics you you shatter the dream
the way I lead is I go do stuff
and when I talk about doing stuff I'm
talking about I move the bar the only
thing I look at every day is did I move
the graph up
I'm just like
I love that the the symbol of Hercules I
think it was Hercules holding the world
yeah and and I imagine if he if it was a
live character he'd be pushing it up
more all the time that that's what I
when I see a graph I look it up we graph
everything right I look grass and I'm
like I want to go be Hercules I want to
lift it and that's all my people see me
doing every day I don't I'm not an
organizer I'm not a planner
I'm not the meeting guy
um I'm the I'm I'm I'm hurt I moved I'm
Hercules constantly moving that bar
moving the bar moving the bar I'm I'm
the one making the points right and so
I'm like look I don't Steve I'm gonna
make 40 points today put 20 on the board
dog I don't need you to do because you
can't Steve you can't make
okay right uh so me me and Ryan I'm like
right right I'm a race I'm gonna raise
two million dollars today I bet you
can't even do half of what I did
um and what happens is
you know they see my energy is toward
activities that get results
not not ideas or concepts people will
listen to three or four or five
influencers
four of which don't make any money
like they're they're more interested in
likes and comments than they are a bank
account
I'm not interested in the influence like
I've never consider myself an influencer
I'm considering myself a businessman
so I want to make money I want my
companies to make money I want the
department to make money I want the
division to make money to the degree
that the the company the division the
household is profitable the country's
profitable it means we're doing good
things and so
um when John comes and listens to me and
then listens to another guy says oh you
need to save your money and I'm like you
need to use every penny you have to grow
your brand
if you got to go into debt to grow your
brand do that if you gotta if you gotta
borrow money
to to get connections do that and this
other guy's saying don't borrow money
well the guy's going to do nothing
Little Dave's going to do he won't do
anything because there's a conflict in
his mind Grant said do it Dave said
don't yeah I won't do anything
so what the problem of maybe too much
information actually was too much too
much information that's conflicting so
he would be better off so I got to make
it clear Dave's wrong to my public day's
wrong
but maybe Dave's right for you but day's
wrong for me because I want to expand
Dave's right for you because you want to
stay small oh by the way staying small
never works people are so uncertain
about their decisions
you don't want to give them any evidence
to be uncertain yeah the presenter's job
is to reinforce certainty over and over
again
re you're doing the right thing people
have made so many mistakes
in their decisions that they become
they basically become people that make
no decision which is a decision by the
way right no decision is a decision yeah
choosing not to act and and and people
don't choose to act because they've lost
certainty because a previous
uh decisions for me like I was always
scared of money you know and and I was
terrified of it so so like if you look
at still today like I look at the bill
of everything
it's a bill of everything if something
calls something I want to know how much
it was
and so like how much is it like I'm
going to ask that question whether
whether it matters or not
um it doesn't matter where I get in my
life I don't think I'm ever going to be
free of how much was that how much is
the dinner how much how much was dinner
how much was the tip how much was the
code how much was the jacket what did
you know me me and Elena like Elena's
like it's gonna be fine man like look
what look look at what you've done we
cannot spend this and I'm like how much
was it
I want to know how much it was because
when I grew up do you had to know what
things cost and so the point your
question about money is is a terrifying
thing because
it's the one thing in life that
you know the NFL is not going to give me
the ball and and I'm never going to get
a chance to golf I can't win in those
environments but with money everybody
gets money it's the one place where
everybody gets it and now what do I do
and I can lose it now
so it's a terrifying concept like like
power you know very few of us ever ever
get any kind of influence or power right
once you get it you're like hey what do
I do with this you know am I going to do
it am I going to do the right things
with it and so I think people withhold
themselves because they don't We're Not
educated about money we don't know where
it comes from we have a lot of
misinformation about it our parents
terrified us you know money doesn't grow
in trees uh save your money it'll save
you all these these these things our
parents told us because they were
enamored
or are encumbered with the same kind of
liabilities around money right I don't
know how to get it
I don't know how to keep it
and the the third the worst part that
we're all at is I don't know how to
invest it yeah so what I'll do is I'll
some people get good at getting it very
few actually fewer people at keeping it
but probably more than getting it
there's probably a big group in America
that have learned how to keep money
because they're afraid to lose it they
don't want to invest it they don't want
to use it they don't want to you know
um you know Kanye talks about this how
white people how white people save all
their money and they just keep it they
just store it like I had an uncle he
buried everything he ever made they went
in the backyard wow the other uncle was
was uh he was he was a guy that bought
he he worked hard very very frugal
Italian descent and he would uh buy real
estate but it was always buy low and
sell hot he actually never sold anything
but that was the concept Buy Low by the
cheapest lowest
get everything on a deal if there's food
stamps to be gotten you go get those
food stamps if there's a if there's a
government deal get it if it's Section 8
and the government will pay you pay it
so both these guys different kind of
mentalities were extremely Frugal my
other uncle was uh worked in a Refinery
he basically saved all his money paid
everything off got out of debt that was
their lifestyle my dad died when I was
10.
so he paid all his debt off had
everything paid and and so that's all I
had right everybody around me was like
get money
keep it keep it don't use it you know
but but you should invest but nobody
ever learns that third one
and and so I think we're just a bunch of
people walking around terrified of this
this apparent apparency of it's scarce
right and it's not mm-hmm
and and you know it's not there's
nothing scarce about it you will never
ever experienced great change in your
life
unless you're willing to give up
something that you have right now
every single time in my life I have had
to give up something I want it so I'm
not talking about getting rid of the bad
stuff you got to get rid of something
that you actually work for to get
might have been the house it might have
been oh my kids are in the best schools
now it's going to be something painful
for you to get to the next place you
have to give up something that you
worked for really really hard so I sold
my house one day I had this cognition
hey to get what you want you have to
give up what you have
that has been true for me throughout my
entire life I had to leave Lake Charles
Louisiana went to Houston had to leave
Houston once I got comfortable with my
community and my friends had to leave
San Diego had to go to La La is a pit
compared to La Jolla nobody goes from La
Jolla California up to Los Angeles
nobody does that
Kansas City go to Los Angeles
because you want to be an actor I met
Elena within five minutes of arriving in
LA
oh
I sold my house I sold my house I didn't
leave it vacant as a backup plan I left
this house okay like I couldn't buy this
house today if I wanted to it was so
like it was a precious little treasure
I had to give that up by the way I had
to give up being the mayor of my little
town everybody knew me it wasn't a
restaurant I couldn't walk into I could
always get a seat I could always get the
best seat I had it right in my hand this
is what I'm telling you guys you have to
be willing to give something up and the
moment you do you better have your
partner on your side
whoever's in your life mom whoever's the
big influence that significant other
person in your life that you're going to
consult that everybody's going to
consult every one of you are going to
hey what do you think should I
you better have that person on your side
in my case I was by myself
so my consultant was like you gonna do
this dog I called my buddy dale dale you
think I should he's like you're
miserable bro you got everything you
want and you're miserable
he's like what do you have to risk sold
the house went to Los Angeles lived in a
hotel I went from a house on the ocean
to living in a hotel the hotel room was
probably like I don't know maybe the
size of this stage so please please do
whatever you got to do this weekend to
figure out whatever you got to do to get
rid of whatever is holding you back most
of which is something you worked hard to
get
okay maybe before the weekend's over you
could write down two or three or four
things you worked really hard to get
that you think you're supposed to keep
you got them already you got it you
already did that you don't have to keep
it you know I'm always keeping it real
with you what has happened to our
country that we make our idols and our
icons and our heroes rappers and
entertainers and ball players and then
we show discuss for a businessman that
can Bank 50 million a year or 20 million
a year what is wrong look when a guy can
go out and make passive Investments
great decisions execute show tremendous
discipline okay and disconcert between
good Investments and bad Investments and
then make 20 million or 30 million bucks
pay three or four million dollars in
taxes three or four million dollars to
his Charities his churches his community
helps out with groups of people
and we have discontent for the
businessman that's out there year after
year making great Investments great
decisions showing leadership in the
marketplace look that Marketplace out
there that economy is the most Savage
most difficult playing field in the
world to negotiate yet
who do we admire in our culture rock
stars look these guys got great skills
kid gets out of school makes 12 million
a first year and and we make posters of
them in sweatshirts and and you put
their kids in their jerseys what about
the business people that make our
economy work they pay the taxes that
make the schools work the churches work
that make the fire department the police
department because they pay taxes
because they're out there making great
Investments look admire business people
they're able to bank year after year
admire these people study them learn
from them don't be disgusted with them
and turn off anybody anybody that would
suggest to you that making money in this
country is Wrong look don't envy
business people admire them emulate them
learn from them particularly these guys
are doing it year after year after year
not just on income but on wealth
development because that's where you
need to be that's where you need to be
thinking that's the economy you want to
create for yourself your family your
household and your future you know this
concept of time management has been
pushed off on me my entire life and I
have never ever agreed with it I'm like
why would I want to manage time
why would I what am I going to do how do
you manage time what do I do I like okay
I'm going to watch these seconds dude I
don't want to manage time I want to
produce I want to be highly productive I
want to squeeze time I literally want to
take time and I want to turn 60 minutes
into three hours of production that's
the different think that you need today
not manage time now there are some
tricks when managing time if that's
where you want to come from like Alan
Greenspan Alan Greenspan and his
roommate in college his roommate's
father taught Alan Greenspan a little
trick that Alan Greenspan used his whole
life and it was to break up the day into
15 minute blocks 15 minutes I have
something and then fill up the next 15
minutes now the reason Alan did that and
I like that concept A lot is because he
didn't want white space on that calendar
he knew white space was a problem
because white space nothing in the 15
minutes is a waste of time
see before you start thinking about just
managing time first I want you to do
this number one I want you to make a
list of things that you're doing every
day that is a waste of time that is the
way you create time not manage it
the first thing I want to do is look at
things that I'm doing that are wasteful
those two or three hours a day that are
wasteful moments things I'm doing on
Facebook that just are waste of time or
maybe a game I'm playing it's a waste of
time or maybe a newspaper I'm reading
where I'm not really learning anything
I'm reading about the the celebrities
it's a waste of time okay second thing I
want you to do is this I want you to
then start thinking about these 15
minute blocks and filling that calendar
up but the third and most important
thing I want you to think about is how
can you create time how can you
literally take 24 hours and and pack
more into it so that you can become more
productive so that you can use that
urgency concept and really blow up your
your career blow up your life make the
most incredible life for your family for
you for the kids for your wife or your
husband and for your clients so that you
can take care of yourself materially as
well people say the dumbest things it
could be family it could be your wife
your husband it could be a a mom a dad a
uncle an aunt it could be your kids
coming from school people say what they
think and what they think will be what
they say and what they say and think
often enough long enough reinforced
enough I promise you will be what they
do okay so look at some of the dumb
things you say like this here's one dumb
thing people say
Time Heals all things really you get a
splinter in your foot and you don't pull
the splinter out you don't look at it
confront it and say I gotta pull that
little booger out I got to pull that
little splinter out if you just leave it
there you might get used to it yeah
you'll get used to it 30 years goes by
you still got a splinter in your foot
who knows that splinter gets into your
bloodstream goes to your heart spikes
your heart kills you time does not heal
all things folks you know what heals all
things taking a look at it Having the
courage to look at it hey what happened
to me how did I screw up here what what
hurt or what pain or what happened that
I had a loss I see people go through
life with all these losses unwilling to
look at them all crippled by the time
they get older not old but they looking
old because they believe that time heals
look Time Heals when you conflict when
you look at it when you pull the
splinter out and take responsibility for
it don't believe everything you believe
you know what I'm saying because some of
the ideas you got they just dumb and
dumb things will cause you to do dumb
things everything everything should be
everything should be used right
everything you're doing should be used
for something somebody's gonna you gotta
assume that you're gonna be successful
and if you're going to be successful you
should document it I promise you you're
going to look back everybody in the room
has done this God I wish I had pictures
from when I was
oh my God where's right yeah because you
were underestimating this is the
tenextual you're underestimating your
potential to be super successful
then you're going to get there and say
damn what was I thinking you were
thinking you weren't going to be
successful and the truth is you are the
organism is going to be successful if
you don't quit if you refuse to quit and
you refuse to stay where you are those
two things you have to do refuse to quit
and refuse to stay where you are you
will get here the organism you as a 60
trillion cells will figure the way out
okay some out if you don't quit and if
you refuse to not be satisfied with this
spot right here that you're at
no matter how tempting the spot is the
true wealth on this planet is helping
other people
like if somebody else how many people
you think will hear in this interview
oh it will be thousands hundreds of
thousands okay so you know maybe if I
help maybe if I help 100 people out of a
hundred thousand
I'm like dude that's awesome
um you know I got family members who are
going to help 100 people in their whole
lifetime if I can help 100 people today
that'd be freaking crazy the other the
other 100
000 that didn't get the message whatever
man go do whatever you want to do I
don't care like I don't even know you
right like like some guy was hating on
me that day I'm like bro I don't even
know you you know me I don't know you
okay understand the calculation that's a
problem
because who knows me is more important
than who likes me
so yeah what what's my exit I don't know
that I have an exit I think the exit for
me is probably the same as everybody
else except I would like to live a
couple hundred years after I die
so my game my game is not the money game
my game even though I played the money
game my game is
could could people actually could I help
people in the year 2150
yeah
that means I found what I did I need to
put it in books
I've written 21 best-selling business
programs okay those programs should be
able to live like when we built
something
when we built something we're like can
this live
50 or 60 years from now when I was 30
years old I hated the sales thing I
hated like like I'm doing this
documentary right now Tom Hopkins I'm
participating in it and he's the guy
that I studied and I studied uh Brian
Tracy and I studied all these guys this
was back when selling was like you ask a
question I answer it with a question
there was no transparency you know you
couldn't shop data anywhere so
everything was slick uh it was it was
criminal it was bordering on criminal
all the time like
um
you know the the oh you I'm gonna put my
thumb inside my hand like this and I'm
gonna model you and match you and I
hated that like I hated the idea that I
had to become someone else every time
so basically what I did was
I tell the story all the time I was
selling fish when I was 19 years old I
mean if I if I'm if I'm selling fish I
just knock on your door and say I got
fish
that was my pitch
I got fish I caught the fish the fish
are fresh and before you say no look at
the fish yeah and I sold all my fish
nice and and so I learned how to do
things transparent in an industry this
is 30 30 years ago car dealers didn't
give you anything there was no books
there was no Google there was no true
car there was none of that right right
so I figured out how to be more
effective
selling with the truth honesty
transparency and authentic authenticity
and I I took that model and I went out
around the country and sold it to a
bunch of Car Dealers that were making
money deceiving people yeah
um
and and so that that was that was a big
thing for me if you took everything away
from me right now the the things that
are most valuable to me you can't take
away
so you take the plane away you take the
money away
take the real estate Port the portfolio
away did it three years from now I'll be
bigger than I was because now I have
courage
if you guys can just find your courage
man
and that that's a muscle you got to go
build a muscle of Courage I have courage
nobody can take that away from you can't
steal it from me you can't beat it out
of me you need an accountability partner
you need someone that you share your
goals with that will hold you
accountable a strong person somebody you
respect a mentor a guide someone that
you don't want to disappoint or let down
pick someone that you can have with you
on your side that you can share as often
as you need to
that your goals are this your actions
need to be that
and you did or didn't handle those
things okay and and have somebody in
your life where they'll hold you
accountable say look come on man you're
better than this let's go do this I've
been using mentors my entire life a lot
of people don't know this at the age of
25 I had a mentor that met with me every
single day to check on me every day I
made commitments every day that person
met with me every day when I got into a
sales game I was 26 27 years old I met
with a guy every day to work with me on
my sales game every day he held me
accountable how many calls I made how
much training I did every day I have had
accountability coaches and mentors for
37 years
because you made it this far in a video
I want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
Nation you made it here all the way to
the end and I love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome if you
want to see the one-on-one I did
recently with Grant check it out right
there next to me I think you'll love it
continue to believe and I'll see you
there true wealth cannot be created
working it can only be created invested
Elon Musk is completely invest
he has no cash and no houses
[Music]